- We're tired.
- Stand up!
- [Together:] Fight back!
- When Asians get attacked:
- [Together:] Stand up. Fight back!
- We're tired of our cries
and anguish not being heard.
- Show me what community looks like!
- [Together:] This is what community looks like!
- Show them what community looks like!
- We're tired of our pain
being overlooked.
- Stand up!
- [Together:] Fight back!
- We're tired of keeping our heads
down or not making any trouble
when our elders are being
assaulted, stabbed and killed.
Wouldn't you be? The hate-fueled attacks
on Asian Americans are disturbing, but
why are we surprised? For many of us
as Asian Americans in this country,
we know what it feels like to be told
we don't belong, that we're
perpetually foreigners.
And even though others try
to minimize us to one entity,
we represent so many different
cultures, so many different
backgrounds, so many different stories.
What do you think happens next in a
society where we've normalized
xenophobia at the highest levels?
- Trump’s gonna f--k you.
- [Offscreen:] You need to leave now.
- You need to leave.
- [Offscreen:] You do not talk to our guests like that.
- No, you need to leave.
- [Offscreen:] What’s wrong with you?
- [Offscreen:] You need to leave.
- F--king Asian piece of s--t.
- [Offscreen:] Oh, my God.
- [Offscreen:] You need to leave right now.
- [Jeremy Lin:] People assign blame
to those who don't deserve it.
People are emboldened to
vandalize Asian-owned businesses.
People feel like it's OK to yell
at you in public based on your race.
Normalizing hate speech stokes the flames
of racism and leads to an 84-year-old
Thai grandfather lying helpless on the
streets of San Francisco, left to die after
being attacked. 84. Years. Old. The next
week, a 64-year-old grandmother assaulted
in San Jose and a Filipino American man
slashed across the face in New York City.
We're tired of this hateful violence.
We're tired of talking about it.
But we're not done
speaking out. Far from it.
Listen to your AAPI [Asian American and
Pacific Islander] brothers and sisters.
We must learn to love one another, to hear
one another's anguish and actually care.
Don't overlook the pain
those around you are
experiencing on a daily basis.
Reach out to offer your support.
To educate others. And let's put an end
to this violence and hate, together.